as security council president russia
proposed a closed-door emergency meeting
on monday night but the u.s insisted on
a public session having earlier stated
there could be no fence sitters in the
ukraine crisis and speaker after speaker
expressed varying degrees of disquiet or
outright condemnation of russia's
recognition of the independence of
donetsk and luhansk the u.s said the
united nations itself was at stake
president putin is testing our
international system he is testing our
resolve and seeing just how far he can
push us all he wants to demonstrate that
through force he can make a farce of the
u.n
the ukrainian ambassador also argued
this was not just about his country
the united nations is sick
that's a matter of fact
it's been hid by the
virus spread by the kremlin
will it succumb
to this virus
it is in the hands of the membership
thank you mr president criticism of
russia was not limited to the west
african nations expressed particular
concern at the breach of the territorial
integrity of ukraine
multilateralism lies on its death bed
tonight
it has been assaulted today
as it as it has been by other powerful
states in the recent past
but russia said it was precisely the
failure of multilateralism that had led
moscow to make its decision specifically
the refusal of kiev backed by washington
to implement the ceasefire agreement
meant to permanently end hostilities in
eastern ukraine and give the region
autonomy the minsk agreement
kiev not only very quickly returned to
militant rhetoric and continued shelling
civilians but also did everything to
sabotage and eventually destroy the
minsk agreements
key to the meeting what now for the
minsk agreement still the only existing
framework for peace the u.s appeared
unequivocal
today president putin has torn the mask
agreement to shreds
russia disagreed
today we can see that many colleagues
want to sign up to the idea that the
minsk agreements are dead but that's not
the case and kiev is still bound to
implement them we remain open to
diplomacy for a diplomatic solution
but permeating the discussion was the
question is this it has vladimir putin
been amassing his forces of the
ukrainian borders not just to force the
west into a dialogue about moscow's
strategic concerns but also finally to
reach a settlement in eastern ukraine or
does the russian president have far
wider ambitions
shia britancy al-jazeera the united
nations